l'événement n'était pas prévu hier soir
il ya une manifestation surprise
organisée par la cgt différents
syndicats d'étudiants mais aussi
plusieurs élus de l'opposition de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'occasion de
la soirée des entrepreneurs organisée au
théâtre saint quentin en yvelines ils en
ont profité pour interpeller les élus et
les employeurs sur le projet de votre
travail en manifestant à l'entrée du
théâtre pendant une partie de la soirée
comme vous pouvez le voir écouter ces
précisions recueillies au micro de
william l ce qu'on conteste c'est
effectivement un tous les cadeaux qui
sont faits au patronat les exonérations
de cotisations sociales ou les lois qui
permettent aux employeurs de
flexibiliser encore plus alors qu'on a
déjà énormément de salariés qui
souffrent de l'intensification du
travail des horaires décalés des heures
sup à n'en plus finir et aujourd'hui on
a un mouvement qui se construire pour le
rejet de la précarité des mauvaises
conditions de travail des bas salaires
donc on est venu se faire entendre des
ennemis des patrons et donc c'est
effectivement très symbolique que
retiens tu de 51 en yvelines ont un haut
lieu de culture tient des rares à avoir
été épargné par la carcasse des
subventions de l'année dernière on
organise aujourd'hui un grand raout pour
tous le patronat local et de à base de
petits fours alors que dans la rue les
gens se battent pour leurs droits